c'est l'une des leçons de cette pandémie
les états africains doivent renforcer
leur souveraineté sanitaires à ce jour
le sénégal ne dispose que de quelques
centaines de milliers de doses de
vaccins astrazeneca et du vaccin chinois
sinopharm trop peu pour couvrir les
besoins d'un pays qui coûte près de 17
millions d'habitants
avec cet accord qui a été conclu ce
vendredi dakar va pouvoir produire mais
aussi exporter des vaccins anti qu'ovide
et cette annonce intervient alors que de
plus en plus de voix s'élèvent ici pour
dénoncer l'absence de solidarité des
pays alliés des alliés historiques du
sénégal les chinois et les russes
donnent des vaccins
les autres font comme bélise
nationalisme vaccinale même le prêt de
la macky sall a délaissé sa part nous
parle de coopération de solidarité mais
mes poulets var 7
ils gardent leur sang pour eux et nous
n'aurons rien et ce sont les autres qui
viennent nous donner des marchés grecs
ici là nous de cet accord a été plutôt
bien accueilli le journal le quotidien
titre même le rêve va devenir réalité le
site devrait se situer à une trentaine
de kilomètres de dacca et devrait
produire 25 millions de doses en 2022
le site produira aussi d'autres vaccins
en dehors des vaccins anti qu'ovide pour
le sénégal mais aussi pour le reste du
continent
objectif permettre à l'afrique
d'accroître sa souveraineté
pharmaceutique et surtout ne plus
dépendre des importations à rappelons
qu'actuellement le continent importe 99
% de ses besoins en vaccins